- The moment right before I jump, there's
a split second there where everything goes
completely silent, and that's when I push
off the edge.
Three,
Two,
One,
See ya!
(wind blowing)
- [Interviewer] Today
I'm speaking with a woman
who kind of blows my mind.
(phone ringing)
- My name is Ellen Brennan, and I'm
a wingsuit base jumper.
- [Interviewer] Don't be modest, Ellen.
What else?
- [Ellen] Currently I'm
the fastest flying woman
in the world when it comes
to wingsuit base jumping.
- [Interviewer] A
wingsuit is a special suit
that inflates with air and
allows you to, in essence,
fly, or glide.
Ellen does this all over
the world at crazy speeds.
- [Ellen] On average I'm flying about
180-190 kmh.
- [Interviewer] That's almost 120 mph.
But to get to that speed you
need to jump off a cliff.
- [Ellen] My vision is
the first thing I notice,
that everything becomes very
focused on just my speed.
My heart's beating super
fast, it's usually beating
like 160-170 beats per minute.
Sometimes people will talk to me and I
won't even hear them.
As soon as I push off, I can hear the slip
of my feet off of the
rocks, and as I slowly
start moving I can hear
the wind start to rush.
(wind blowing)
(light music)
- Woo hoo!
Like, it's something
that shouldn't happen.
It's not natural, but I'm doing it.
How in the world did I
get to be able to do that?
It's one of the coolest
things in the world,
like, I can't think of anything
better to do (laughs).
It's pretty mind-blowing.